I think the hardest for a part of the
process was finding an apartment oh my
god oh my god I mean I'm a Japanese
citizen and it was still a pain in the
ass you hear about on YouTube and
Twitter and everything like it's hard
it's hard and then you see some people
saying like yeah it's people Irv
exaggerating it is it is not a design
hot [ __ ] difficult especially if
you're a foreigner is while you
basically play under different rules
yeah it's not to say like you know in
the UK I think if you have money you're
getting a problem I think more
importantly especially if you are a
youtuber because the the hardest thing
at least in Japan from my experience
about why it's so hard to get a [ __ ]
apartment here is because freelancing is
not a job here yeah freelancing you
might as well be unemployed according to
this government slate the government's
like that typical Asian parent yes like
what you're not a doctor or an engineer
or a lawyer you're working part-time and
that's due to because they're worried
about if you can pay all the rangoon
what yeah right but the thing is is that
they don't even like you know at least
in like I don't know about the UK or
Thailand but at least in Australia you
when you sign up for like an apartment
right usually the landlord will be like
okay can I see your bank account yeah
like just to see how much money you have
saved up regardless of what job you do
we just want to see that you have you
know money
yeah bank and if you do it then you're
like okay but here in Japan they don't
check your bank they check your work
status to make sure that there's like a
constant flow of money calm yeah and
it's not just that as well cuz if you're
not Japanese
and it's especially if you can't speak
Japanese most places aren't even going
to talk to you or consider you that was
a big problem we had because we went
through like an agency and we just made
us lists of about 10 to 20 apartments
that we were interested in and we sent
it off and applied for gents rejected
from all of them Christ and we had a
company as a guarantor yeah yeah having
the like payments secured wasn't the
issue it was like a lot of the time it
was really dumb stuff like yeah can you
sort the bins properly and like yes 12
year old
it's like the main concern you'll hear
all the time is can you sort your trash
properly and it's like okay it might be
different from where I'm from but like I
can learn yeah it's like the government
councils in the area give you an English
manual that tells you how to do it like
it is tedious and it is a lot more
complex in most places but it's not
rocket science it's not like you're
having to do like the weirdest stuff
imagine of all of this stuff like it's
basically just rinse your stuff separate
all of it that's pretty much it and I
know there's some places in Europe they
do way more thorough that plate don't
have this concern when they land letting
people yeah houses it's just like it's
the least of your concerns it's you know
yeah ridiculous yeah and the thing is
that if you'd go through an agency for
example that specializes in foreigners
and people who can't speak Japanese
you're gonna be paying so much more for
that ability pay like a premium for that
bill and that rents so it's you you
either have a [ __ ] difficult time
finding a place and getting past all the
barriers or you're just gonna pay a [ __ ]
ton of money and those aren't two very
good option the only concern that they
often cite our building managers etc
that I find is like somewhat alright
that's fair enough is that they're
worried that you'll run away yeah but
run away and not pay the rent but if you
have a guarantor that's the whole
[ __ ] point of that problem we can't
run away you run away you're still
getting your money like yeah yeah and
the house is vacant great no damage to
it like this is a win-win for the
company I don't understand like we do
you play by their rules because it's
just like typical like this is like one
aspect of like Japanese it's definitely
one of the work culture that I learned
very quickly it's that like it doesn't
matter what the business is if they're
not 100 million percent sure that this
is going to go through yeah it might no
they don't do risk you know recently any
business venture whether that be paying
for rent or like anything like if
they're not 100 million position in
every possible Avenue ever it's just not
happening and you know that's ridiculous